lots of conservatives are embracing
caitlyn jenner's candidacy for
california governor
and you know that i have been a little
slower
to embrace the stiletto-clad deck
athlete
and a lot of people have said oh that's
terrible michael it's transphobic it's
no let's do it it'll be great
caitlyn is totally going to turn
california conservative again
well now caitlyn has spoken out for the
first time about his campaign and you
know how much i hate to say it
you know i do i'm i can't can i even get
the words out
i was totally right i'm michael knowles
the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from sylvia j
walker who says if liz cheney is so
afraid of the capital riot on january
6th
what would she have done if she lived
through portland seattle los angeles
reality
what alternate universe was she living
in then it's still
going on right but that doesn't matter
when people like
it's not even just liz cheney when when
these squishy republicans
you parrot democratic talking points and
say that
january 6 was the single worst most
horrific
shocking terroristic event in the
history of the united states and they
totally ignore
what happened just six months prior
during the blm and antifa riots what
they are telling you is
not that they oppose political violence
it's that
they think that some political violence
is kind of justified
and some political violence is totally
unacceptable and the political violence
that comes from the left even if they
don't like it
they think that that is look we just
have to expect that that's just what
they're going to do
and we're not going to do that but we
can't really stop that so we're just
going to tolerate
the leftist political violence but we're
really going to stop it on the right
and i just sort of think no let's treat
it all the same
let's treat it but but the the squishes
cannot do that because
they serve primarily to be the court
jesters in the kingdom
of liberalism if you want to remember
olden times like the times of kings and
queens and
nightly courts and if you just want to
remember the memories of your own family
you got to go get legacy box legacy box
is a super simple mail-in service to
have all your video tapes camcorder
tapes film reels and pictures
digitally preserved on a thumb drive dvd
or the cloud
legacy box is a way for you to easily
and affordably preserve your past the
process
from start to finish is so easy you pack
and send
their team digitizes everything by hand
you enjoy
you get these perfectly preserved
digital copies on a thumb drive dvd or
the cloud
ready to watch and share and enjoy you
know how much i love this thing
legacy box is to me the great
saving grace of all you've got all this
physical media that in my case got
a lot of it got lost all of it is fading
you send it in there and it ain't going
to fade when it zeros and ones and then
you get the physical media back that you
can enjoy but you can future proof it
for a limited time legacy box is running
a 50
off mother's day special order your
legacy box today
take advantage of this incredible offer
it's one of the best discounts they've
ever offered
legacy box perfect for you or for
someone you love go to legacybox.com
knowles save 50 while supplies last that
is legacybox.com
knowles caitlyn speaking out
to sean hannity on fox news it was a
very long
interview you can go watch the whole
thing it's it's perfectly illuminating
but there were three distinct moments
where i thought okay this is telling me
what i need to know
about the caitlyn jenner candidacy the
first one it starts off
well it starts off with a recognition of
my
what i think is perhaps the most
important conservative virtue it's
certainly up there
which is prudence it's the common sense
and that's what caitlyn is going to base
his candidacy on i've kind of played
around with that term
um and originally i started out as a
compassionate disruptor and then i was
thinking the other day
i think i'm more of a thoughtful
disrupter i have common sense
okay i see what's going on and i see no
common sense in politics
and why they're doing it besides only
for political reasons
a man dressed as a woman
wearing high heels is telling you that
he has
common sense and the thing is in
california politics
relatively he probably does and i don't
mean this in any insulting way
bruce jenner has been an outspoken sort
of republican you know
more republican than democrat for a long
time and i think he actually does have a
fair bit of common sense
there's just one problem there's just
one glaring problem
that he fundamentally misunderstands
human nature or if he doesn't even
misunderstand it if he merely just
wills to contradict human nature that's
a problem too
you can't claim the common sense when
you're a man wearing stiletto heels
you just can't no matter how smart you
are on
fiscal policy and i think he's fairly
moderate and reasonable on fiscal policy
no matter how reasonable you are about
crime he's much more reasonable than
any democrat politician on crime in
california
on immigration we'll get to immigration
in a second he's a little squish on that
but sure he he has relatively more
common sense on a lot of important
policy issues
but he does he doesn't have common sense
okay but when it comes down to it
he doesn't have common sense so on the
parts where he's he's relatively
good as a candidate what is that about
it's about
the economy stupid to quote james
carville it's all about the economy
i have always been on the republican
side just because i have
conservative economic values i you know
the old same
lower taxes less regulations you know a
more friendly business environment
and we don't have that in california but
socially
i've much i've been much more
progressive all my life i
i get it people do need help you know we
need
programs um but you cannot have
social programs without an economy it
doesn't happen you just don't have the
finances do it
and that's what's happening here in
california and so
it's been so frustrating for me
i don't care i i work for i honestly i
like everybody
i'm friends with everybody i don't like
everybody there are people i don't like
in life
i can get along with anybody sean you
know i can get along
so honestly i don't really care if
you're a republican a democrat
a libertarian vegetarian you know it
doesn't make any difference to me
um i want solutions if the democrats are
able to come up with great solutions i
am behind that 100 oh gosh
this is almost the worst answer he could
have given
because it starts off okay he says look
i want
typical 2000's republican economic
policies
i want less regulation i want lower
taxes
i want a friendlier business environment
okay that's fine
then he says but on the social stuff i'm
i'm quite progressive oh well that's not
great
because ultimately politics comes to
culture and culture culture ultimately
comes to religion
right that's where it derives from and
these religious premises what is a man
what is a woman what is our human nature
what are we here for what are we doing
what is the nature of liberty is liberty
the same thing as licentiousness or is
it the opposite of licentiousness
very important debates our founding
fathers thought one thing all the smart
people throughout history and in
politics thought one thing
and in modernity we we think another
thing
but then he starts even beyond that
where you think okay look if if you
lower taxes
but completely gut the culture
that's not a good trade that's the trade
that republicans made for 20 30 years
now and it hasn't worked out very well
for us
but also he's not even saying that he's
that fiscally conservative because what
he's saying is
i su not only am i progressive in the
sense that i think men can become women
i'm progressive in the sense that i
think we should have a big welfare state
right he's saying we need social
programs but you need a good economy
to support that welfare state he's
basically just bill clinton
this is just what the new democrats did
this is what this is actually
in terms of political analogies here
you had this period after reagan after
the end of the cold war you had george
h.w bush
bill clinton george w bush and to a
lesser degree barack obama
who were all basically the same
president
certainly the two bushes in clinton they
had the same policies
make the economy better for business
especially big business and
make permit basically anything anyone
wants to do on the social front
and support the consequences of those
lifestyles with
bigger government programs that's what
they all did
so if you want to go back to bush and
clinton vote for caitlyn jenner that's
what you're going to get
and then you just get into the pandering
which is so clintonian so
and actually fairly bushy as well
remember you had ronald reagan who says
i'm a conservative then you had bush
come in
bush the first and he says we're going
to be a kindler
gentler nation and nancy reagan famously
responded kindler and gentler than whom
how dare you george bush you're
insulting us
then you had bill clinton come in goes i
feel your pain
and then you had george w bush say i'm
going to be a compassionate conservative
what as opposed to all the cruel
inhumane conservatives before them and
that's what caitlyn's saying here
look i get it i get it we need to take
care of people
i'm just for solutions i can i get along
with anybody i love sean's response he
goes i don't know i don't really like
everybody
some people i think maybe not no sean
i'll get along with anybody and then the
tell that caitlyn has here
is he goes and honestly and honestly
and honestly when people use the phrase
honestly or when they say to be honest
to be totally honest
that's always a big red flag to me
because what that tells you is they
haven't been honest with you up until
this point
if you need to alert your audience to
the times that you're being honest then
you're not being honest at other times
and then what i felt was really
really a low point of the interview of
an already pretty low interview
he gets to a very important issue in
california
immigration here's his answer i am all
for the wall
i i would secure the wall we can't have
a state we can't have a country without
a secure wall
um you have two questions here one is
stopping people from coming in
illegally into the state and then the
second question is what do we do with
the people that are here
we are a compassionate country okay we
are a compassionate state
um some help
i mean some people they're we're gonna
send back okay
no question about that but i have met
some of the greatest
immigrants into our country um i had a
guy the other day
and he was spanish and i've known him
for 17 years
he is the nicest greatest guy he would
make i mean
i would do everything for him to stay
here
and um so you have to deal with it
we have to modernize we have not
modernized our immigration system in the
united states to make it possible to
people
to immigrate into this country such a
ridiculous
such a ridic we haven't made it possible
for people to immigrate in here we take
more immigrants than anyone else on
earth and it's not even close and we've
done it for 60 years what are you
talking about we need to make it easier
for people to come into this country
make it easier the majority of americans
want to dramatically reduce
all immigration both illegal and legal
immigration
according to fairly recent polls there's
a great harvard harris poll that shows
this
what on earth are you talking about well
look
look i think we need to build a wall
yeah i support i support
immigration enforcement okay i'm with
you so far and we need to grant amnesty
to the people who are here what why oh
my gosh caitlyn you want to
give a path to citizenship to
tens of millions of voters who are going
to skew overwhelmingly democrat
sorry to break it to you there have been
plenty of public opinion surveys about
this and wish casting about
these how these illegal aliens are are
republicans they just don't know it yet
that's just not true
it does it never shows up there's no
evidence of that so you're saying
let me catch my breath here i'm so
frustrated by this you're telling me
i've got to give up gender the
gender ideology i've got to totally
accept that i've got to give up the
fundamental distinction in human nature
totally mainstream this delusion which
we've at least generally held the line
on in the republican party and in the
conservative movement for some years now
i've got to give that up so that we can
get a squish
republican who is
fairly moderate on economics
who is politically totally
unpracticed and who wants to give
amnesty to tens of millions of illegal
aliens
and who's going to lose the race by the
way that's that's why i've got to give
up
the most is fundamental premise that the
left is trying to push
and has been trying to push for years
are you insane are you out of your mind
totally crazy it just shows you the
naivete the political ignorance where he
says look what are you
you've got to do something with the
illegal aliens no you don't
no you don't they came into this country
illegally i'm not saying you've got to
deport them all that's probably
impractical
but why on earth do you have to give
them amnesty just
just leave it as is but but they're
living in the shadows
yeah they should leave they broke our
laws and they're in our country
illegally
i i think they should leave but if
they're not going to leave you don't
need to encourage it you don't need to
incentivize it
totally totally wrong-headed
not not a whole lot of common sense
there
you know it's very difficult to tell the
difference between men and women these
days one thing that can sort of help you
tell you know if you don't have features
like that swarthy skin
you know nice swoopy hair and you know
nice big adam's apple here things that
really show you what a man is
one thing that can tell you what a man
is a giant beard
you gotta check out beard supply that
second tier of manly mental right
just below the manliest who look a
little bit like you know
they grill meat they drink handcrafted
booze and they grow
beards thanks to the manliest giveaway
ever some lucky guy
will be doing those things for free
enter to win a stash of goods
from beard supply meet church desert
door howler brothers and more
great brands for the red blooded
american male one lucky winner will get
a collection of beard oils and grooming
essentials tools for grilling and
leather care
and a 200 gift card for an outdoor
menswear shopping spree
so up your man game with the stash of
goods
but don't delay the beard supply spring
giveaway is ending soon so head on over
to beardsupply.com
giveaway to enter that is
beardsupply.com
giveaway to enter there is so much great
stuff in there
you can feel like a really really great
man beard supply
slash giveaway stash of goods
the big problem with caitlyn jenner is
not even
his policies which are pretty squish in
some cases they're
further left than most democrats and in
some cases they're just kind of moderate
i don't know arnold schwarzenegger type
republican bushy republican clinton type
of policies
okay whatever is that better than
newsome maybe maybe not okay fine
but the real issue is no matter how much
caitlyn says
we are i'm not gonna push the
transgender ideology
if you elect a man who thinks he's a
woman
to high office you are mainstreaming it
especially if you are the party that is
at least nominally standing against it
right now democrats are already trying
to mainstream but if the republicans do
it then that's over
that's it we have conceded that there
are conservative
commentators and conservative
politicians who refer to him
as her and i get why they do it it's
hard not to do it
i did it the other day by accident i was
talking to someone i said i don't know i
think she's pretty i said oh my gosh i'm
doing it now too
because it's a very seductive ideology
i'm not saying caitlyn jenner is
seductive i'm saying the ideology is
very seductive
and people are doing it on television on
the conservative
putatively conservative news shows
they're calling him her
we will be doing that and that is too
great a cost
for sort of slightly maybe more
conservative
economic policies and basically the same
immigration policies maybe a little
slightly more concern it's just not
not worth it as far as i can tell
because that is
that ideology is very dangerous you're
seeing it being mainstreamed right now
not just in
politics but in popeye's chicken shops
there was a fella dressed up as a lady
who had a breakdown because
allegedly some guy to popeye's my
favorite chicken shop
called him sir i'm gonna be telling your
manager this guy called me
sir how you getting this time is every
day everywhere i go i get called cern
why would you call a chick
why would you call i didn't say no stop
trying to gaslight trans people and tell
us that we're crazy
wait what did you call me sir again
what was that you said goodnight sir
this is transphobic harassment
oh my god
people need to be held accountable for
how they treat trans people
and i'm not going to put up with this
anymore you're crazy bro you're
so this guy obviously should not be in a
chicken shop
he should be in a padded cell because
he's
not in his right mind if conservatives
mainstream
caitlyn jenner then that crazy guy is
right
then the guy throwing the big fit
screaming the words that guy is in the
right and the popeye's employees
if they called him sir or whatever
they're in the wrong
because we will be tacitly but but
clearly accepting the premise that a man
really can become a woman and so
when even beyond the guy freaking out in
popeyes when you hear these
these promises well look we support
gender ideology for adults but not for
children what are you talking about that
doesn't make any sense
either a man can become a woman or he
can't become a woman
if he can become a woman that's true for
children just as it's true for adults
if he can't become a woman that's true
for children just as it's true for
adults
it's not even a slippery slope it's just
it's just you're there it's just the
same thing
and so we can say no no but we're going
to protect children from this why if
it's true then why would you protect
children from the truth and if it's
false why would you mainstream it
why would you embrace that you think
you think that i'm talking to those
conservatives who want to mainstream
caitlyn
you think that you can just keep these
these
declarations about reality totally
private
what you're embracing is the anthony
kennedy view
that at the heart of liberty is the
right
to define our own conception of
existence
of of life this is what antonin scalia
mocked
as the sweet mystery of life passage
from the ridiculous
decision uh planned parenthood versus
casey
by the supreme court which i talk about
at length by the way in my upcoming book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds available now for pre-order
the you obviously you do not have
any right to define your own conception
of existence in reality
reality has the right to to impose
itself upon you
because also if you have 300 million
people defining their own concept of
reality
then you you have an insane asylum
nation right you
you can't actually have a nation because
we have to agree on certain things
we have to be at least playing
theoretically in the same
in the same game here and reality
doesn't change just because you want it
to change
you think you can keep these things
private but your private act this is
where the
the radical left actually gets it pretty
right your private actions do have an
effect on public life
but but we hear from the left and we
hear from the squish republicans they
say oh just mind your own business
just hey if that guy wants to make a
nuisance of himself in popeye's mind
your own business well
those guys in popeyes were minding their
own business but that guy wouldn't let
them mind their own business samantha b
just made this point
you don't think that a man should wear
stilettos mind your own business
this year we're seeing a tidal wave of
transphobic legislation targeting kids
largely in retaliation for president
biden's executive order to protect
trans rights conservatives are staging a
coordinated attack on trans kids by
making up a problem that absolutely
doesn't exist
most of the legislators who sponsored
anti-trans bills this year can't even
cite a single
instance where trans girls competing in
sports has caused problems
rather these laws stem from the very
incorrect misconception that trans women
are not women
they falsely claim trans women
automatically have more testosterone and
therefore more muscle mass than cis
women
but studies don't show a consistent
relationship between testosterone
and athletic performance so why are
conservatives actually targeting trans
athletes
fear-mongering baby just like with the
bathroom bills republicans are trying to
scare their base into voting for people
like
governor if life didn't go well pat
sajak let's be
real conservatives don't actually care
about this they just want to politically
profit from excluding trans people from
yet another public space
at the end of the day republicans need
to stop policing other people's bodies
mind their own
business and let trans people live their
lives yeah just mind your own business
so obviously the the
factual claim she's making are just
completely wrong the idea that there's
no evidence that there's ever been an
athletic issue here there's a court
there's a case at the supreme court
right now
it's working its way up the courts that
the alliance defending freedom is
working on i think we've talked about it
on the daily wire quite a lot so yes it
has happened
many times the uh idea that
the anti-anti-trans bills are infringing
on trans rights no
the question is what is the definition
of a person
these republicans they don't really care
about this they just they just want to
harm people they just want to
you should just mind your own business
we are minding our own business why
don't you mind your own business
samantha b mind your own business we're
here we've been in this society now and
in civilization
for i don't know um ever you know just
about forever we've
we've been from primitive man all the
way up to
this alleged height of civilization that
we're living through right now
we have always at all times everywhere
believe that men are men and women are
women so
just mind your own business and if you
you disagree with that reality then
just stop pushing this on me but this
has nothing to do that
this has nothing to do with minding your
own business this has everything to do
with
with dominating the business with
declaring
the rules of engagement with defining
the standards
what you know you always hear this well
hey
get get your get your morality out of my
politics
well your samantha b's imposing her
morality on our politics get your
religion out of my pocket you're
imposing your religion on my politics
your religion says a man can be a woman
my religion says it can't
only one of those religions is going to
win out and i think it ought to be mine
because mine's correct so
and everyone has agreed with that for
all of human history until about five
seconds ago
you can't just keep these things private
and conservatives worse than
leftists almost have given into this
idea well just leave me alone get off my
lawn yeah
that goes only so far as
the force of law comes in and tells you
that you
your world view is no longer permissible
and that's the point that we're at right
now
this stuff is going on in first grade uh
yaff
young america's foundation just
uncovered this in a first grade class in
bellingham washington a teacher is
educating her children in transgenderism
reading a book
some transgender book teacher's name is
jennifer miller she said yes i did read
the book
as a district we're working hard to
support all members of our school
community and promote inclusion through
understanding and compassion
concerned parents reached out to
administrators but they refused to take
action
why why did they refuse to take action
while the president of the school board
operates a sex boutique called wink wink
in downtown bellingham
which is a quote gender inclusive woman
owned
all ages sex shop all ages
what on so it's a kid's sex shop
you're a huh well that's just her
private life
that's just her private views no it
clearly has public
effect as well this sort of thing is
being mainstreamed
and conservatives are just we're
twiddling our thumbs when we're not
outright embracing it
this kind of stuff going on in schools
there's a report out from the new york
times the 3 million kids dropped out of
school this past year
when you read stories like that you
think oh good what a relief what a
comfort
the new york times by one estimate
three million students nationwide
roughly the school age population of
florida
stopped going to classes virtual or in
person after the pandemic began
according to the the new york times
now notice what they do here this is
very
relatively subtle for the times but they
say
a three million students roughly the
school-age population of florida
stopped going to classes they're doing
this because there is a prejudice in
this country against
florida against the south generally
against florida specifically you know
florida man all those kooky rednecks in
florida
the florida kids didn't stop going to
school florida's the most open state in
the country
the kids who stopped going to school are
in chicago in new york and
california and all over those places but
they they point they say oh it's
because it's the numbers right it's just
making a comparison by the numbers no
they're trying to
insinuate that it's somehow republicans
fault or the rednecks or the
southerners no it's not it's the libs
that are keeping the kids out of schools
but frankly
i'm not sure that's such a bad thing
conservatives we just get so
we're our own worst enemy so much of the
time because we point out
that these schools are indoctrinating
children into
radical leftist ideology that teaches
them to hate their country
to question their own nature and doesn't
doesn't teach them
or offer them a liberal education so
that's what's going on in the schools
then along comes this virus and takes
the kids out of schools
and then we complain that the kids
aren't in schools isn't that a good
thing
isn't this an opportunity to rethink our
education system i understand
it's hard for students especially the
social aspect it's really hard and it's
especially bad if they're not if when
they're at home they're not even
learning
the the basic sort of edifying
things that they would have been
learning in school the parents should
step up there the community should step
up there yeah
that's i don't actually mean to minimize
the experience of the students
but the government education in this
country
i mean public education broadly i'm even
including a lot of the private schools
here
is very destructive so if we have this
opportunity where three million kids are
not being steeped in that kind of
insanity maybe we should take that
opportunity i think the libs would take
that opportunity they never let a crisis
go
to waste the population of florida
florida's doing just fine thank you very
much
and ron desantis is taking victory laps
because this guy has been right about
coronavirus
from the beginning and he's fighting
back again he just gave a press
conference
you'll notice he's looking a little
thinner he's wearing better tailored
suits it's almost like this guy has
his eyes on a bigger job i don't know
i'm not i'm not
making any predictions here but one
might think he's setting himself up
for 2024. ronda santa says we gotta we
got to cut it out here with this
craziness at the cdc
florida was right and everybody's got to
open up think about the larger
implication of this
do you want one unelected bureaucracy
to be able to have the power to
indefinitely shut down
a major industry in this country they do
not have that authority to do it
that's why we're suing them but this has
much larger implications
than just cruise ship sailing or not
this has implications for potentially
any industry
and look with all due respect to the cdc
i mean if you look at some of the stuff
that they've done
on school openings where they're
basically doing the teachers unions
bidding
when they say these these kids should be
masked at summer camp outdoors
i'm sorry that's not science that's
politics that's not science
that's politics it's a good line ron
desantis is good at these lines he's
obviously set himself
up very well in 2024 and i i'm not i'm
really not knocking him he's doing such
a great job i i don't i don't want to
nitpick
but this distinction here that's not
science that's politics
that's a meaningless distinction in
secular progressivism in a country
that's run by the administrative state
he says the cdc
doesn't have any right to run our lives
for us yes it does
yes it does the progressives for a
century now
have empowered these agencies that are
relatively unaccountable to the people
to run our lives they've done that and
that is the way our government works i
know it doesn't look like it works that
way
in the constitution but that is how our
government works
and we have outsourced through the
progressive project
our political decisions largely to
egghead experts
who pretend that there's no debate over
any political questions
because that's just what the science
says so the real issue here is not
i just i fear we fall into this trap
where we
agree with the left that well whatever
the science says we need to follow that
the science should dictate our politics
but just in this case
that's not what the science is saying
just in this case with the cdc they're
not following the science of politics
no we should go back and say no i don't
care what the science says
the science is meaning this method of
material inquiry
does not dictate my politics i truly
don't care it's not my issue with dr
fauci is not just that he gets it wrong
it's that he shouldn't be running my
life he also gets it wrong a lot
but that's that's not the issue my issue
isn't just that the cdc
is overstepping its bounds where it gets
to run our lives because of science no
my issue is that the cdc
at all is trying to run my life i don't
mind the cdc giving advice i have no
problem getting the advice of experts
but ultimately i want these decisions to
be made by politicians you know who the
experts are
at at politics in a self-governing
republic
the people we're the experts we're the
experts that that
everyone's supposed to defer to within
the constitutional boundaries
and that has been totally disrespected
i'm not desantis has done a great job so
i'm really not knocking him for it
but it's you got to watch the language
the language is
very important here the left has brought
a lot of changes in society
through subtle shifts of language which
is a topic i discuss at great length by
the way in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling lines
available now for pre-order the audio
book
the autographed first edition the kindle
and the hardcover
speaking of the politics of science
cory bush a representative on the
democratic side wants you to know all
about the politics of birthing people
every day black women are subjected to
harshness harsh and racist treatment
during pregnancy and child birth
every day black women die because the
system denies our humanity
it denies us patient care i sit before
you today
as a single mom as a nurse as an
activist and as a congresswoman and i am
committed
to doing the absolute most to protect
black mothers
to protect black babies to protect
black birthing people and to save lives
as far as i know corey bush supports
abortion so i don't think she cares at
all about black babies and
in terms of the birthing people it's a
birthing person oh a woman that's but
you're not allowed to say woman anymore
because the left embraced transgenderism
and guess what if the conservatives go
all
in on caitlyn we are implicitly even if
we say we're not
we are implicitly embracing that kind of
language too
she this woman corey bush she she might
be even to the left of aoc though aoc
had
a pretty wild line i have to get to it
before the mailbag aoc
is out defending planned parenthood for
saving lives she begins she says
conservatives i don't want to hear about
planned parenthood
when you support the death penalty first
and foremost
i don't want to hear a single person on
this committee or outside of this
committee
talk about what about uh
valuing life when they continue to
uphold the death penalty
when they continue to support policies
that disproportionately incarcerate
and lead to the deaths of black men and
people throughout this country
and uphold in a in absolutely
unjust medical system that exists for
profit
that allows people to die because they
can't afford to live
put a pause right there i don't have a
lot of time so we'll do this quickly
executing convicted criminals
is different than murdering innocent
babies the u.s justice system
over it intentionally incarcerates
criminals that's what they go for if if
some groups commit crime at higher rates
that ain't the cops fault that ain't the
system's fault
it's a problem but it ain't the cops
problem and third
the united states has the best health
care in the world that's why people from
other countries that allegedly have
better health care when they want good
health care they come to the united
states and then she goes on and makes
her her real point
in addition to that if we want to talk
about planned parenthood
let's talk about how many lives planned
parenthood
has saved and how many babies have been
born because of the prenatal care
provided by planned parenthood
and if you don't if you don't believe it
and if you've never met a planned
parenthood baby
i'm happy to let you know that i am one
and that my mother received and relied
on prenatal care
from planned parenthood when she was
pregnant with me
and so if we're concerned about life we
don't get to talk
about anyone else who's not concerned
about the full spectrum of that
when we are upholding policies that kill
people
so that's obviously preposterous for the
argument she's making if aoc really
if her mother did go to planned
parenthood at various times and i have
no reason to believe that because aoc
lies all the time but if that's true if
aoc
slipped through the cracks of the
abortionist ghouls at
planned parenthood that's good good for
her that's a that's a good story
the fact is that planned parenthood
kills hundreds of thousands of babies a
year
their business is abortion if
accidentally some woman walks in and
they don't they're not able to get their
fangs into them
and and convince them to kill their
babies that is a happy
accident that happens at planned
parenthood but the argument she's making
here is if you
don't oppose the death penalty you can't
you can't
oppose abortion not true if you don't
support socialist medicine you can't
oppose abortion
not true you can you really can you
don't need to fall for the traps that
the left is laying before you
even when that involves candidates on
our own side
that are that are i think tricking us
wittingly or unwillingly into
into accepting a lot of very dangerous
leftist premises you know every day on
my show i talk a lot about the
fabulous products and services from
sponsors that i love to use
we want to get to know you better so we
can choose our sponsors with you in mind
so please head on over to dailywire.com
knowles fill out my audience survey to
tell us a little more about yourself to
sweeten the whole experience those of
you that complete the survey will be
entered to win a 1
000 gift card you can only take the
survey once per daily wire show so if
you want to increase your chances of
winning a thousand bucks
go listen to ben go listen to drew go
listen to matt get access to their
surveys
as well my survey link is dailywire.com
knowles we would love to hear from you
also starting tomorrow saturday may 8th
episodes of ben shapiro's new series
debunked will be released every saturday
on apple spotify or wherever you get
your podcasts you can also go to
dailywire.com and get 20
off today with code debunked to get all
episodes now each episode ben dismantles
leftist talking points in less than 15
minutes in the first episode
ben debunks the absolute fallacy
of a living minimum wage i'm interested
in hearing that one myself go check it
out we'll be right back with the mailbag
welcome back to the show first question
from lisa marie
hey michael i have a problem at work i
recently moved to a new city for work
and have not fully
settled in there is a guy at work i have
a crush on but there are a few
complications
he's much younger than me i'm catholic
and he's a practicing jew
and i am about five inches taller than
him do you think this is too much of a
divide to be bridged
does height and age really matter thanks
a lot
sincerely romeo and not a juliet
well done well done not a juliet
there are a lot of complications here
not the least of which
you don't even really get to it or
acknowledge it but
not the least of which is you work
together so if things don't work out it
could be a little bit awkward
it could be even worse than awkward so
you know you got to take that into
consideration plenty of people meet at
work so i'm not i'm not saying
that's a deal breaker but something to
consider in terms of the
age it could be an issue the only the
only way it would be an issue
necessarily is with kids
i think i mean you know age creates
complicated i've i've friends who are
married who have big age gaps and it can
be a problem it's not always a problem
but it can be
but with kids it could really be a
problem because if if
the timing is not going to work out and
he really wants kids then
probably this thing isn't going to work
for you as for the religious issue
if you want to be married and remain
catholic you know if you want if you
want to be married in the church
then you would have to agree to raise
children catholic that's the way that
you would get a dispensation from the
bishop for an interfaith marriage
and really really he would have to
convert
right because you you need to be unified
you can't have a family that believes
radically different things like that
and if the man is going to be the head
of the household which is pretty
traditional
then if you're not going to convert to
judaism and
as a fellow papist i would suggest you
do not do that
then you would have that trick and
that's not impossible plenty of people
start out believing different religions
and they come together
but but you'll either grow together or
grow apart
not saying you can't go get a drink with
the guy in terms of the
height you know if you don't have a
problem with it he doesn't have a
problem with it then who cares you know
think about nikola sarkozy the former
prime minister of france
who you know he was dating that hottie
who was much taller than him and that
was made him look like an even cooler
guy
so that i wouldn't worry about that but
uh and in terms of you know in terms of
the age it's
there that is a little bit more
difficult than it than it would be
uh in terms of height but you know you
could suss it out you don't need to
decide whether or not you're going to
spend your lives together on the first
date
but you shouldn't drag it along either
and put yourselves in a bad situation
that will be harder to get out of
from jared dear michael my brother's
wife has excluded me from mother's day
because i have not gotten vaccinated
ugh my parents and every other adult who
will be at the celebration
have been vaccinated but she doesn't
want me exposing my seven-year-old niece
who's at what like point zero zero zero
zero zero one percent risk or so no
that's not an exact figure but
it ain't that far off i'm not an
anti-vaxxer i'm 31 years old
had coveted last december and i don't
understand how a vaccine can improve my
own god-given immunity
i respect her impulse to protect her
child but i don't see how my presence
puts
my niece or at any more or less risk my
sister-in-law
is acting out of fear at best and at
worst passive aggressively punishing me
for not marching to the beat of fouchy's
drum what would you do
well i might i might tell my brother
that he could consider acting like a man
and get control of his household good
grief he's you know what just your
clearly your sister-in-law wears the
pants in the family doesn't she
goodness gracious he's just your brother
is letting your
sister-in-law tell his family what to do
there are clearly deeper problems here
than than the
vaccine and the neurosis that your
sister-in-law is
expressing with the vaccine clearly is
given free reign
in that household so that would be
that's the first problem your brother is
the first problem
but and if you look at the statistical
likelihood
that a seven-year-old child is going to
face serious complications from kovid it
is it's
virtually non-existent so that's not a
good argument
uh and yeah i i would not do it
i would not i would not get the vaccine
for that reason
um i wouldn't want to miss out on
mother's day either
so i try to arrange maybe you know you
have breakfast with your mother or
something like that
but if your sister-in-law is going to
boot you from the
dinner or from the lunch for a
completely bogus reason and your
brother is gelded and refuses to
tell her no then what can you do you
know you don't you shouldn't acquiesce
to that sort of ridiculous demand and
maybe go get breakfast or go get a
different meal instead
from sandy last week walsh had a segment
where he dissected a statement that
steve harvey made
on how it's impossible for a single man
to be just friends with a single woman
man i'm getting a lot of relationship
questions today
he agreed with harvey but what is your
take
yeah basically that's true it's
it's difficult for married men to be
friends with single women
it's not impossible it can happen but it
has to be the case that
you've got you know you're not sexually
attracted to one another
that the that your wife is part of that
friendship too then it
that it can work but if a if a married
man is
friends just completely on his own with
a single woman that can create
some complications um
in terms of single men and single women
yeah it's virtually
impossible to do it unless you're really
not in
any way attracted to one another but but
that's rare
and that sort of thing can change as
well so and the question is if you're a
single man and a single woman
and you really enjoy spending time
together then why would you want that to
remain
totally asexual
or platonic or why why would you even
want to do that if you you know if it's
working out then why don't you you know
see where it goes from james
michael i want to push back respectfully
against your thoughts on caitlyn's run
for governor
wow that's funny because obviously this
question came in days ago and then my
show today was all about this
isn't it possible for the gop to support
her run
especially if she has a viable shot at
winning without accepting the premise of
transgender ideology
i'm not interested in owning the left
although it would be a great trolling
opportunity
but can't someone vote for caitlyn
without accepting the transgender issue
please keep up your great work you're
the most based host the daily wire thank
you very much for the compliment
no it is not possible and you just
proved it because what did you say i'll
pull it up right here
you said isn't it possible for the gop
to support
her run if she has a viable shot at
winning
without accepting the premise of
transgender ideology you just accepted
it
you the premise of transgender ideology
is that a man can become a woman
and we ought to treat men who who
believe that they are women as women
and you just did that and you didn't
mean to i assume i assume it just
happened because you look and he's
wearing stilettos and he's wearing a
dress often and he's got long hair and
he vaguely resembles a woman and
everyone else is calling him her so
you're going to go along with that too
the most ardent opponent of this madness
and the
most ardent defender of reality will
crack a little bit if the whole culture
is telling you that
the man is a woman and if even the
putative conservatives
are going along with it i don't i'm
trying not to be
totally close-minded here never say
never and paul never say never trump
right
for instance never say never in politics
but i just
do not see a way for conservatives
to embrace kate even if caitlyn isn't
particularly conservative anyway but
even if he were even if he were the most
hardcore knuckle dragon right winger
i don't see a way for them to embrace
him
as her without giving up the game on
gender ideology
as i think you just demonstrated from
daniel i really love the show
and i wanted to tell you that it is
largely due to you that i am joining a
local church hey great
a couple years ago i got divorced which
was at fault against me
for reasons i won't get into in the
mailbag i'm working on fixing the damage
to others and myself that i caused
but what i wanted to ask is how could i
possibly move forward
my friend tells me that now i need to
just jump back into dating however i
have a huge feeling of guilt from the
divorce
even still and if i find someone i don't
want to bring that in and have another
failed relationship because of it
if you have any good advice it would be
welcomed but if there is no good advice
then honesty will be appreciated as well
either way i know
that whatever you say the results will
leave me speechless oh
but you know that's my new book that's
titled my new book coming out uh
controlling words controlling minds
available now for pre-order
very difficult situation i'm so pleased
to hear that you've joined a local
church and i'm very
pleased to hear that i had some role in
that drew clavin tells me that whenever
that sort of thing happens
we get a toaster in heaven so that's
great i'm very excited
you're in a very difficult position you
should not listen to your friends
your friends just might not know what's
going on
here's a hard saying my friend sorry to
tell you this
you can't get divorced you can't do it
now the question of divorce
is is a question of what is the marriage
what was the marriage
so i'm speaking here as a catholic this
is the
the old-timey view this is the
long-standing
christian view of marriage and divorce
what god has joined together let no man
separate
now if you're
if you've split up and you say it was
your own fault and sure these things
happen people get divorced i totally get
it
it's in the mosaic law right
if you split up you get divorced
this does not mean necessarily that you
can never date again and that you can
never marry
but what you have to determine is
whether or not
your marriage was a was a valid marriage
in the first place
which is why the the process here in the
catholic church is not divorce one
cannot get divorced but there is
an investigation for the for the purpose
of annulment and what annulment says
it's not
okay you had a marriage and now you're
gonna dissolve that marriage
what annulment tries to figure out is
did you have a valid marriage in the
first place was something concealed
before the marriage that that
makes a fraud or a farce of the
of that marriage vow did the people who
were getting married
know what they were getting into in the
first place now
the difficulty for you i'm not i'm not
sure if you're catholic i i suspect
you're not
by saying i joined a local church and
say you know you're kind of just getting
into this
back when i was coming out of my 10
years of atheism i
checked out some other protestant sorts
of pastors and things too
so i i understand that process i'm not
familiar with a non-catholic
process for this investigation this type
of annulment
um so obviously i recommend the catholic
way to do things um but you should
figure that out first
uh because you i think your your
intuition is totally right and you're
gonna have the whole culture telling you
you're wrong but you're totally right
if you've got these unresolved questions
these unresolved issues you shouldn't
just immediately jump into another
relationship that then you could get
married and then that could be failed as
well you need to work these things out
first yourself and ultimately what are
you working at you're working out your
own salvation with fear and trembling
and you're trying to figure out things
that and you're hearing things that
might be hard sayings but you remember
as you've joined your local church that
christ's
yoke is easy and his burden is light
even if it doesn't always look that way
even if it looks like it's the way of
the martyrs
i would work that out first i think that
it might be a little difficult or it
might involve some discipline in the
short term
um but i i would never give in to
despair
and i would never fling yourself you
know there's the sort of despair of oh
my life's never going to get better
and the sort of despair of i'm going to
fling myself into something immediately
because i have no idea what else to do
and that could create further problems
as well
i would investigate first what was the
nature of your marriage at the very
least why did the marriage fall apart
and
was it was it a valid marriage in the
first place from aaron
michael huge fan of the show and all the
other daily wire material
my question for you has nothing to do
with politics or the culture war that is
going on right now
actually i was curious if you are ready
for the upcoming cicada arrival now that
you're living
in tennessee speaking of
scenes from the bible yes i am preparing
myself for the
actual biblical plague that is supposed
to be happening apparently trillions of
cicadas these
hideous gross gigantic bugs are about to
come out and they're especially going to
come
into dc uh not not great stuff
very very bad stuff i'm preparing myself
to not leave my home
for a couple of months from sarah since
you show a
passion for history i was wondering who
you thought were a few of the most
important women
in history not including the virgin mary
thanks well you know you have to include
the virgin mary i guess
most of the women that i think of is the
most important in history are
saints you know i think of saint lucia i
think of saint
catherine of siena i think of saint
teresa of avila i think
he's very important to rezablish you for
that matter
very important reformers very important
people
there have been important statesmen too
i mean obviously elizabeth the first was
extraordinarily important elizabeth ii
was
extraordinarily important even if i
don't totally go along with everything
that they did is it queen isabella oh my
gosh she was essential
toward the creation of america she
counts too but they all do seem to have
this
religious grounding as well right
isabella
devout catholic the elizabeths heads of
head of a church you know elizabeth it's
kind of weird that elizabeth ii
is a head of a church when
no one in her country seems to believe
in that church anymore but but she
doesn't so yes i think those women
are plenty in statecraft but they do all
seem to have a kind of cultural and
religious basis too as does all politics
got to take a break
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show hold on tight for just
two days and we'll be right back on
monday
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
board
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 hey everybody
this is andrew clavin host of the andrew
clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin
[Music]